good afternoon today we are going to get
lost in translation is how to use that
this was this was you are yeah this is
the first the movie was second after
this I'm going to talk about how you
make proteins from messenger RNAs
remember that messenger RNA which is
central to all those genomes I'm going
to talk about how that's made into
protein or translated into protein in
particular how viruses manipulate the
system to do what they want so we're
going to review a little bit of
translation first just to make sure sure
we are all at the same level and then
we'll move on to what the viruses do so
in eukaryotic cells
this is a typical messenger RNA at the
upper right it is a messenger RNA
encoding an open reading frame which is
translated to make one protein and this
typical eukaryotic mRNA has a 5 prime
cap structure usually an untranslated
region at the 5 and 3 prime ends and a
poly a sequence at the 3 prime end and
the cap structure looks like this it's a
very interesting linkage instead of a 5
to 3 prime linkage which is typical of
the bases in the mRNA or in DNA a 5 to 3
prime linkage there's the phosphate bond
between the 3 prime end of this base and
the 5 prime end of this base the cap is
actually a guanosine and a sugar linked
5 prime to 5 prime so it's inverted
normally this would be linked 3 prime
but it's a cap structure it's different
there are 3 phosphates in the other
linked 5 to 5 Prime and this cap is
found on most eukaryotic mRNAs with a
few exceptions and in fact some viral
RNAs mRNAs do not have caps we'll talk
about some of those and it's often
methylated and that's important for its
function it has a variety of roles it
has an important role in translation as
we will see today
but it also has roles in processing of
mRNAs transport mRNA turnover and today
we'll talk about the need for it for
efficient translation there are
untranslated regions in the mRNA and
these will factor in our discussion
today there's a five prime untranslated
region it's usually about 50 to 70
nucleotides average on most cellular
mRNAs but it can be very short or even
over a thousand bases and we'll talk
about the implications of that it often
has secondary structures those hairpins
and stem loops and so forth in the RNA
and those structures would normally
impede the ribosome as we will see the
ribosome has to travel from the cap to
the first Aug and if you have secondary
structure that will impede the passage
of the ribosome so the amount of
secondary structure in this front prime
UTR will affect the efficiency of
translation of the messenger RNA it's
followed by the open reading frame of
course begins with an Aug and then ends
with a stop codon and then we have a
three prime untranslated region which
also has roles in regulating translation
efficiency and also stability of the
mRNA and that and the poly a tail here
which is necessary for efficient
translation the mRNA of course is
translated by a machinery that includes
ribosomes and here is the composition of
a eukaryotic ribosome this is the entire
ribosome its sediments at-ats in a
sucrose gradient and it is made of two
subunits the 60s and the 40s subunits
and those of course are made of both RNA
and proteins a couple of RNAs for the
big subunit and one for the small and
thirty and fifty different proteins and
this is the structure of the ribosome it
was solved a number of years ago in fact
Nobel Prizes have been awarded for
solving the crystal structure of the
ribosome this amazing feat because these
are big assemblies big macromolecular
assemblies
we now know how they look and that's
what this diagram on the right is
derived from now in this picture the RNA
is pink and yellow
and the protein is blue in fact you
could take away all the protein and this
what's left the RNA can still make
proteins it can still catalyze the
peptide bond so the RNA is actually
probably is most important for making
proteins and this may be a relic of the
RNA world when there was just RNA and no
protein and these may have evolved way
back then there's also T RNAs and we
will talk about tRNA is a bit so let's
make sure we understand them these are
shorter RNAs whose job it is is to
transfer an amino acid into the ribosome
during protein synthesis and there's one
of course for each amino acid sometimes
more than one and there is a part that
recognizes the mRNA the anticodon and
then there's a part where the amino acid
is attached and these have secondary
structures as well as you can see here
these are highly structured and you can
see that here the anticodon is down here
it's an L shape structure with an amino
acid attachment site up here and these
are examples of phenylalanine tRNAs so
this would be the codon for
phenylalanine fee would be linked up
here and as part eight would be here as
well so tRNA so the translational
machinery in addition to ribosomes and T
RNAs in eukaryotes consists of
initiation proteins we call those EIFS
elongation proteins which are called ee
F's and termination proteins which are
called ER f's
for some reason they're not called ETF's
do we know why sorry what okay ETF
anyway these are ER F so you have to
remember that so let's talk about
initiation which is the step at which
most of the regulation occurs in
translation which is not to say that it
it doesn't occur at other steps but it's
the best understood there are two main
ways that ribosomes bind to eukaryotic
mRNA there's the one called v prime
dependent initiation which happens
probably our most mRNAs in cells the
initiation complex binds to the cap and
moves down to
initiation codon which can be an Aug but
it can be other codons as well that was
the one we knew of for many years until
viruses revealed the second one which is
internal ribosome entry and this is
where the initiation complex binds just
upstream of the initiation codon it
doesn't need a cap to work the ribosome
can bind internally hence the name
internal ribosome entry so that was
discovered with viruses in fact it was
discovered with poliovirus and really
changed our understanding of how
translation works so let's take a look
at the first mechanism the five prime
and dependent initiation some people
call this cap dependent which isn't
perfect I think five prime end dependent
is better and this depends on having an
MRA with a five mRNA with a five prime
cap which is down here it's the little
blue box so what we need to do is bring
the ribosome to the mRNA and eventually
to the Aug so we start with the 40s
subunit and this 40s subunit binds a
number of initiation factors GIF three
in particular is very important and then
the ternary complex comes in the ternary
complex consists of the tRNA with the
methionine on it that's the initiator
trna II I f2 with GTP that's the ternary
complex trna if to GTP and then another
factor e I F one comes in as well and
that's placed on to the growing complex
here this becomes a 43's initiate pre
initiation complex another protein comes
in called the I F for G that's the red
one and binds this as well and the red
one will in turn bind ew f 4e now EIF 4e
is this curved purplish molecule here
which is actually the cap binding
protein this protein if we has the
ability to bind the cap we don't
actually know the sequence of events the
precise sequence of events here it
doesn't really matter what you see
happens is that if where he binds the
cap in turn a if4 he binds to EIF
gee we'll look at that more carefully in
a moment
gif 4G is binding if 3 which in turn
binds the 40s subunit so you see we have
a complex of protein-protein
interactions which brings the 40s
subunit to the 5 prime end of the mRNA
that's why we need a cap structure in
order to enable this in the process we
also have the ternary complex in here so
here there's a initiator tRNA ready to
start translation because remember the
mat is most of the time the first amino
acid which is put down and then this has
to scan and find the Aug so we do
believe that this complex in some way
moves to the Aug we don't know how that
happens we don't know when the cap is
let go or if the RNA is threaded through
this this is an unsolved problem but
that complex does have to get down to
the Aug now gif 4G is a very interesting
protein its large 220,000 Dalton's and
it's shown in a linear diagram up here
it has binding sites for many different
proteins it has a binding site for iif
for a gif 3 EIF for e and poly a binding
protein and this is the way he is 4g
orchestrates the interaction of the 40s
subunit with the cap so gif 40 is the
cap binding protein it has a binding
site at the n-terminus of if 4g that's
right there and 4g also binds the if3
and if 3 in turn binds the 40's CIF for
a is an RNA helicase and this is very
important to have here in this complex
because if you have secondary structure
in the 5 prime UTR that has to be
unwound by this RNA helicase so an RNA
helicase will unwind double-stranded RNA
so if you have a lot of such structure
you need to have this CIF for you a
present so here's a summary of the next
few steps we've made our initiation
complex on the mRNA and remember if if
there is secondary structure which is
diagrammed here you got to have that
GIF for ADA unwind it this is an
atp-dependent helicase so in other words
unwinding this RNA requires energy so
you get energy hydrolysis as the complex
moves down the mRNA and eventually it
will reach that Aug codon and then the
met tRNA will base pair and start
translation when this Aug is reached a
lot of these factors are released you
can see here we don't need them anymore
the gif three for example is released
EW f/4g is gone and also the the factors
associated with the ternary complex come
off a if' 2 comes off and in the process
of this met trna sitting down getting
ready to translate this GTP is
hydrolyzed to GDP so this placement of
the met tRNA in the Aug codon requires
energy and that's important we'll see
later on
so try and remember that this ternary
complex comes apart it leaves of course
the tRNA behind but hydrolysis of gtp is
needed
once this once this happens the large
subunit can then come in and associate
with the 40s subunit and now we're ready
to begin protein synthesis we have a met
tRNA sitting in the P site of the
ribosome and now we can put a new amino
acid in the a site now we also think
that the 3 prime end is involved in this
translation there is a protein in cells
called poly a binding protein P a B 1 P
it binds poly a sequences and it also
binds the N terminus of VI f/4g a few
slides back there was a diagram of
binding sites for other proteins on the
AF for G and one of them is PAB poly a
binding protein and there's quite a bit
of evidence which suggests that the RNA
ends have to be brought together by
these interactions in order to get
maximally efficient translation so
there's genetic and biochemical evidence
unfortunately no one has actually
visualized in a Cell a circularized
RNA but there's a lot of other evidence
which suggests that this is important
for efficient translation why it is so
is not clear one idea is that after if
you have a circular mRNA when you stop
translating so the ribosome goes to the
stop codon maybe it's easier for the
ribosomes to recirculate on the mRNA but
nobody really knows if that's true or
not okay so in virus infected cells this
basic system has been modified and
expanded for a variety of reasons that
we're going to talk about that now
and one of these types of expansions is
called ribosome shunting now basically
what viruses will try and do is to take
over the entire translational apparatus
of the cell so as you will see they will
try and shut off the translation of host
mRNAs they want to have the ribosomes
and the tRNA is all dedicated to making
their proteins viral proteins so I will
talk about some ways that that happens
but in turn the viruses have to have a
way to escape their own inhibition of
translation and this is one of them so
that's why we're talking about
modifications of the translation
apparatus to make the viruses have the
system dedicated to them but also not to
be inhibited by their own actions
so ribosome shunting is an interesting
mechanism whereby we think that
ribosomes bind the cap just as I've told
you this happens on viral mRNA is they
bind the cap and then they pass over
most of the five prime UTR okay so that
is shown by this experiment where we we
have made a messenger RNA it's capped
and it has a lot of secondary structure
in the utr and this secondary structure
of course would have to be melted out in
order to get translation of of the
protein and this is a Western blot on
the right where we're looking for the
protein that is made by translation of
this mRNA so if you take this wild-type
mRNA and you put it in a cell or in a
translation extract you get proteins
made now if you put a very stable
stem-loop structure right here right
next to the
that's shown in red so this is a stem
loop which is so stable it will for sure
block the movement of ribosomes and
prevent them from getting to the Aug we
know this this has no effect in this
position on protein synthesis so somehow
the ribosomes are getting around it if
you put the same stem loop here at near
the 5-prime and it blocks translation of
this mRNA all right so this shows you
that the stem loop in itself is enough
to block the passage of the ribosome
here only so we think that the ribosome
is begin to scan and they can scan past
this region and this blocks it so they
normally would scan through here and at
some point in here they are released or
transported in some way directly to the
Aug I will show you a model for that in
a moment so that's why it's called
shunting the ribosomes are shunted from
one part of this utr to the other so
they can shunt over this stem loop but
they can't apparently shunt over this
one so that's the evidence for our
ribosome shunting and this is a model
for what we think happens the ribosomes
bind at the 5-prime and they scan a bit
and then they reach some secondary
structure which can then hand them off
directly to the Aug we really don't know
how this works this is fanciful drawing
it's kind of a direct translocation
which doesn't require scanning so the
putting in a stem loop structure doesn't
affect this nevertheless these stem loop
structures are important for the
shunting apparently the ribosomes can
bind to them and are transferred in some
way so this is observed to occur in the
mRNAs of a couple of different viruses a
plant virus an adenovirus and and sendai
virus and we think one of the reasons
why it occurs it's predicted to decrease
the dependence of mRNAs for gif for F
now if for F is the whole complex of VI
F for a for G and for e at the five
prime end of the mRNA now remember if
you have a lot of secondary structure in
mRNA you need to have that gif for a
helicase now the shunting is predicted
to get around the need for melting so
the virus could in some way inhibit this
if for F
complex so that cellular messages are
not translated yet it's messages can be
translated because they have this this
shunting mechanism that allows them to
get over secondary structure
so that's ribosome shunting another
different way of translating is internal
initiation and this is as I said first
discovered for poliovirus RNAs when the
poliovirus genome was sequenced it was
found there was a very long five prime
non-coding region at the five prime end
so this is seven hundred and forty
nucleotides longer than most five prime
utrs that had been discovered up to that
times about 1980 or so and it wasn't
clear how the ribosomes would get
through this because this is full of Aug
codons which would impair ribosome
scanning so in addition what made this
RNAi complex remember this is an mrna
this is a plus strand RNA genome it's
also an mrna it was not a cap at the
five prime end had a little protein
linked to it which if you remember from
our talk on RNA synthesis is the primer
for RNA initiation so there's no cap how
do the ribosomes attached to this RNA
and how do they get through all of these
aegs well someone had the idea that
maybe this allows ribosomes to bind
internally so they did this experiment
they made two different mRNAs and they
both have two protein coding regions so
one here in orange and one here in blue
so you're making orange proteins here
and blue proteins here now this is a
capped mRNA if you put this in a cell
you make a lot of orange protein but
remember eukaryotic mRNAs are not very
good at making more than one protein so
most of the ribosomes will fall off
after making the orange protein and very
few will make it to the second protein
coding region it's just a fact of the
way eukaryotic mRNAs work so we have one
blue protein here to illustrate that not
many of those are made if you take this
sequence from the five prime end of
poliovirus RNA that sequence here
this 740 some base sequence you make a
DNA copy of it you put it into this
construct you make it and you make it
RNA of course eventually this is an RNA
so that's this sequence here in the
middle which we've labeled ir es and
then you put this into a cell now you
can make a lot of orange proteins as
well as a large a lot of blue proteins
so somehow this sequence enables the
ribosomes to get inside the mRNA and
initiate translation and it was called
an internal ribosome entry site or iris
that's where the name comes from now on
the bottom is another experiment that
was done this was done instead of
putting these RNAs into regular
uninfected cells they were put into
polio virus infected cells now as we
will see later in polio virus infected
cells the five prime end dependent
translation is completely inhibited so
ribosomes cannot get on to the five
prime end they're blocked at loading
onto the cap well we'll talk about the
mechanism so this mRNA is absolutely not
translated at all no orange proteins are
made no blue proteins because the
ribosomes can't load its again it's a
polio virus infected cell but if you
take this RNA where you have an iris you
make plenty of blue proteins because the
ribosomes don't need a five-prime end
which is blocked by polio infection to
translate the blue protein they can load
internally which is not affected by the
block at the five prime end so this
showed that internal ribosome entry
actually bypasses a five-prime and
that's why I like to call the other
mechanism five prime end dependent
because this one is not
you don't need a three five prime end so
internal ribosome entry site was coined
to describe this now this predicts that
a five prime end is not needed but it
doesn't prove it but the following very
cool experiment does prove that so if
you want to prove that a five prime end
is needed for five prime end dependent
translation but not iris dependent
translation you make a circular
MRNA and you can do this by ligating the
ends together you have to make a little
I'll ago nucleotide that bridges the
ends and then you can light them
together you make circles like this and
in this experiment we have two circular
mRNAs one has an iris and the other
doesn't and this has an Aug so this is
the open reading frame for a protein and
this one has the same open reading frame
but no iris this RNA will make protein
when you try to translate it because the
ribosomes can bind to the iris this one
has no iris the ribosomes can't
recognize it there's no free five prime
end with a cap so they can't translate
it so this shows that an iris doesn't
need a 5 prime end in order for
translation to occur and what does an
iris look like well what color is an
iris irises are blue usually these are
what irises look like these are from a
variety of different viruses this is
poliovirus
iris here the one that we that was
originally studied this is another virus
related to poliovirus encephalomyelitis
virus here is the iris of hepatitis C
virus of virus in a different family
entirely and then here is a the iris of
an insect picornavirus so polio and EMC
V are all pokorny viruses as is this one
so you see first of all the yellow parts
are the iris part here here here and
here they're all different the sequences
are completely different and even the
structures are different so you actually
cannot look at a nucleotide sequence and
say AHA that's an iris because there's
no signature the structure is very
important for the ribosomes to be able
to bind but it's very hard to scan for
such structures when you're looking at
sequences so for all of these irises the
ribosome will bind internally very close
to the Aug and initiate translation and
a five-prime and is not needed you could
circularize all of these rnas and they
would still be translated the let's talk
a little bit about how these work and
we'll start with the virus of hepatitis
C virus which is one of the simplest so
hepatitis C virus is in the flavivirus
family and other members of that family
would be West Nile virus and this virus
has a RNA genome which is shown here it
has an iris at the five prime end and
the ribosome the 40th subunit can bind
directly to this highly structured iris
remember here this is the hepatitis C
virus iris panel see it's highly
structured the ribosome will bind it if
you take purified hepatitis C virus RNA
and purified 40 s subunits and mix them
they will bind so this RNA has evolved
to be able to bind directly the 40 s
subunit so the 40 s binds the iris
without any proteins and that places the
40 s subunit right on top of the
initiation codon and then eiei f3 can
come in and this the big subunit then
comes in as well so this is an example
of this very simple RNA protein
interaction the RNA of the virus can
interact directly with the proteins and
RNAs of the ribosome now for other
irises it's probably a little more
complex
here is the Hep C iris for reference
just the ribosomal 40s subunit can bind
the iris this is a iris of say the
corner viruses here we think more of the
initiation proteins are needed for
binding in this case we believe that if
4g binds to the iris which then if you
remember binds the CIF 3 and then the
40's subunit so it's a little different
from the Hep C example where the 40's
combine the iris directly here it has to
engage EF for G now why the end terminus
is broken here you will see a bit later
that that is an interesting question so
this is interesting compared to cap
dependent translation or 5 prime end
dependent translation remember the cap
is essential for bringing the complex to
the 5 prime end you don't need a cap for
an
with an iris mrna the ribosome can be
brought by direct protein RNA
interactions now since these viral
irises were discovered many many more
were discovered in viruses and on the
left is a list of viral irises so we
have them in many different virus
families I told you about pakora and
flavivirus irises there are also viruses
and the pesty viruses retroviruses have
irises as well as do the insect pakore
know like viruses and we also have found
irises in cellular mRNAs in a variety of
genes which are shown here and this we
don't quite understand because these
mRNAs that have these irises also have a
cap at their 5 prime end and it may be
that at certain times in the cell cycle
5 prime end dependent translation is
inhibited we know this occurs during
mitosis for example and it could be that
if you need certain proteins made during
that time you put an iris in them and
they can continue to be made but proving
that has been a little difficult alright
let's go back to the initiation step now
we remember we went through the whole
initiation step of 5 prime end dependent
initiation ending up with the met tRNA
in the p-site ready for translation
there are very interesting examples
among viruses of Mosiah mean independent
translation so the year we have a met
tRNA sitting down on the Aug so the
ribosome has scanned down the mRNA looks
for the first Aug as soon as it finds it
it puts a tRNA there there are examples
of Metheny and independent in not only
cells but in virus infected cells and
here are two of them this is an example
where you don't need an Athenian tRNA
because the viral RNA folds in a way
that mimics a tRNA so this is a viral
RNA it happens to be a plus strand RNA
we'll talk about in a moment the very
five prime end is folding in a way that
looks like a met tRNA so not
at tRNA but an initiator tRNA this
happens to be initiating at a prolene
triplet although there is no amino acid
placed in here because this is not
charged with an amino acid all right so
this RNA can initiate translation
without a met tRNA the first amino acid
to go in in this case is an alanine in
the in the a site here again because the
RNA is folding to beat to look like a
tRNA even though there's no amino acid
attached to it so that's one example and
there's another one this is a plant
viral RNA where the three prime end has
a tRNA like structure this is actually
charged with valine you can see the
valine amino acid is attached here so
this sits down on a valine codon and the
first amino acid to be put in as a
valine so the RNA three prime end mimics
a Metheny initiator instead putting in
valine we're not sure why they do this
at all now the RNA genome of cricket
paralysis virus is shown here and this
is as far as I know the only eukaryotic
viral mRNA where you have actually to
open reading frames separated by an iris
now an iris would in theory give you the
ability to make multiple proteins from
one messenger RNA right so you could
have five prime and you could have one
open reading frame you could have an
iris a second open reading frame an iris
a third open reading frame you could be
like a bacteria which can do
polycistronic mrna s but we don't see
that at all I don't know of any mRNAs
and eukaryotic cells where that happens
except for this one so this is cricket
paralysis virus it is a picornavirus it
paralyzes crickets that's how it was
discovered in Australia the farmers came
out one morning and saw paralyzed
crickets on the ground and they sent
them to a virologist and the virologist
identified this virus so people are
trying to figure out if it can be used
for pest control the interesting thing
about the virus went sequenced it would
look almost like polio except instead of
one long open reading frame it was split
in two and there's an iris in between
here labeled igr intergenic region so
this is an iris splitting to open
reading frames there's also an iris at
the five prime end and vpg just like the
picornaviruses now this iris here looks
like this and in fact this is the this
is a sequence that can mimic a tRNA so
that's the one I just showed you before
the way initiation works on this iris is
that the ribosome binds internally and
the RNA mimics
the tRNA so that initiation begins
without a methionine codon but the
interesting point here well they're two
interesting points this is very
interesting the Metheny independent
initiation but also the fact that you
have this is a polycistronic mrna which
only happens in bacteria and is the only
example that I know of that so here's
the problem
and we're going to talk about other ways
to get around this so eukaryotic mRNAs
are typically mono so Stronach one mRNA
one protein bacterial and archaeal mRNAs
are polycistronic you can make several
proteins from one messenger RNA and
that's because at the five prime end
around the Aug of each of these Orff's
there's a shine-dalgarno sequence which
is complementary to a sequence on the
ribosome ribosomal RNA so the ribosomes
can bind internally on these bacterial
mRNAs most mRNAs and eukaryotic cells
can't do that with the exception of that
cricket paralysis virus I don't know why
they don't do it because you could put
irises into these mRNAs and make
multiple proteins in fact we do that in
the lab all the time if we want to make
two proteins from one mRNA and mammalian
cell we just put an iris you can buy
irises from companies just for that
purpose make two proteins from one mRNA
but they are not naturally occurring
alright so this problem this mono saw
Stronach limitation is gotten around by
many viruses because we've mentioned
this before you know many viruses is one
RNA genome you have to be able to make
multiple proteins so I want to tell you
now the different ways that viruses get
around that or I call it maximizing the
coding capacity of the viral genome so
here are some of the strategy
we're gonna talk about and some examples
of the virus families that utilize them
we've talked before about the poly
protein strategy I just told you about
internal initiation we'll also talk
about leaky scanning reinitiation
suppression of termination and frame
shifting so these are all very
interesting ways to get more than one
protein from a message in a eukaryotic
cell and they're all discovered with
viruses and some of them happen in
uninfected cells as well poly protein
synthesis you have seen kornev viruses
make a poly protein and chop it up with
proteinases that way you can get a dozen
proteins from one mRNA so that's obvious
there are other plus strand viruses that
toga viruses do the same thing they make
a poly protein and processes so
different viral families do that
internal ribosome entry we talked about
the RNA genome of cricket paralysis
virus making two proteins by putting an
iris in between them and that's the only
example I know of this these two
proteins by the way are in fact poly
proteins on their own so these are also
processed to give more proteins leaky
scanning this occurs in the genome of
paramyxovirus which are negative
stranded RNA viruses with an envelope
and here is an interesting example these
these viruses make sub genomic mRNAs and
make seven or eight sub genomic mRNAs
from the negative strand RNA genome and
we're looking here at one of those mRNAs
that encodes for this one mRNA encodes
for one two three four five six seven
different proteins by this interesting
leaky scanning mechanism actually two
two of the proteins are made by RNA
editing so you remember RNA editing is
when you make the mRNA you insert an
extra base during transcription which is
not templated so you shift the reading
frame
so you can make this protein in this
protein which have different C termini
but the C proteins 1 2 3 4 are all made
by leaky scanning so let's see how this
works so we have a cap at the 5 prime
end the ribosome binds and it starts to
scan down and it reaches this ACG codon
ok now a cg can be an initiator trna is
will bind to that but it's not very
efficient
so maybe ribosomes start translating
only 5% of the time so they make this C
prime protein but a number of ribosomes
will keep scanning without initiating
and then they reach this Aug at 104
that's an Aug codon so the ribosome is
like that but you know the surrounding
sequence around an Aug is very important
for the efficiency and we call that the
context of the Aug and this Aug has a
really bad context so again a few
ribosomes translate and make this P
protein but many of them continue to
scan then they reach this Aug at 114
which is an Aug and it has a great
context yes
sure good question
I mean this would be uninteresting if
they weren't functional right yes you
can do experiments to eliminate each of
these proteins and they're important so
they differ at their end terminal and in
fact this one is in a totally different
reading frame the pea protein that's why
it's brown here so this is a totally
different protein from the others which
just differ by the length of their end
terminus but they do have important
functions yeah yeah yeah so the context
is bad hmm around the Aug there are a
couple of bases on either side which
have to be a certain sequence to get
maximal initiation it's called the
consensus sequence and if in eukaryotic
mRNAs there are really no perfect
consensus mRNAs because every mRNA
doesn't have to be translated to its
maximal efficiency so that Aug I 104 has
a bad consensus surrounding the Aug and
then we have so these these are leaky
scanning 81 104 and 114 these two
proteins are RNA editing and then these
two here very interesting Aug 183 and
201 these are made by ribosome shunting
remember that mechanism where the
ribosomes jump the long distance that's
what they do here they start to scan and
then they get past Aug 114 and the
number of them are still scanning and
they jump to 181 or 175 so it's amazing
from one mRNA the virus has evolved to
be able to make multiple proteins yeah
right so the context in this and the
code on the nature of the code on just
allows more ribosomes to pass over it so
that you can get the downstream protein
made well you need apparently you need
to make all of them right but you don't
need all of them at the same levels and
this just ensures you that eventually
you get to the downstream one right so
those are the three made by Leakey
scanning and then the others are
different mechanisms as well all right
what else we have reinitiation of
translation so most cellular messenger
rna's I told you you make you have an
open reading frame you make one protein
but there are a couple of examples of
viral RNAs where there are some short
open reading frames actually within
what's called the non translated region
obviously this is not technically a non
translated region but it would normally
look like one because it's upstream of
the main open reading frame but in some
virus-infected cells you can make these
short proteins they're called upstream
open reading frames and the ribosomes
keep going and then they reinitiate at
this downstream Orff so you can make two
proteins from one mRNA that's one
example of reinitiation the second one
is an influenza virus mRNA which can
code for two proteins called M 1 and B M
2 what happens here's the ribosomes
initiate here they make this protein UA
a as a termination codon so they stop
but look the UAA is part of the next Aug
so they reinitiate immediately so
normally after terminations ribosomes
move a little more and then fall off but
there's nowhere to go here they move
they see an Aug and boom they start
translating again so that's another kind
of reinitiation yeah
now it doesn't in this case it's just
that's the actual open reading frame but
the protein begins right here
yeah these no but there is an example of
that which we will get to overlapping
reading frames reinitiation then we have
suppression of termination so view
proteins synthesis stops when the
ribosome reads a termination codon how
does that work so you make proteins by
adding charge T RNAs to the a site and
then a peptide bond is form and here's
the growing peptide chain and then you
throw away the the tRNA without the
amino acid so this one has just been
linked to the growing peptide chain if
this were a triplet for the next amino
acid a new tRNA would come in here and
then it would the amino acid would be
linked up to this chain but this is a
termination codon you a a it is
recognized by termination factors ER F 1
and e are F 3 and those are shown here
the these factors basically look like at
tRNA but they sit in the termination
site and there's no tRNA there there's
no amino acid so that's halts
translation so that's how termination
normally happens you have these
termination factors recognizing the
termination codon and remember the three
of them and termination and translation
stops but sometimes these stop codons
can be recognized by a tRNA that has an
amino acid on it and that's called
suppression of termination and obviously
allows translation to continue and that
happens in a number of viral genomes
here is one example
it is a retro viral genome and here's
the mRNA made by this retrovirus
retrovirus is encode AG AG protein at
their 5 prime end this is the structural
protein that forms the core and appall
protein which has reverse transcriptase
and RNA SH and integrase in this
particular retrovirus there is a stop
codon B
between the gag and the pawl coding
regions right here you a G so ribosomes
begin to translate this mRNA they make
gag and they stop how do you make
envelope polymerase if you don't make
polymerase you're never going to reverse
transcribe well right downstream of this
you AG there's this very interesting
structure it's called a pseudo knot it's
a stem loop where the the unpaired bases
in the loop base pair with a downstream
sequence you showed a picture of this
sometime ago and apparently this causes
the ribosomes to pause the ribosomes hit
this structure and they pause and that
gives enough time for a tRNA to actually
sit into this UAG site and put a TIA an
amino acid there so this can be a miss
reading of the codon which is usually
what happens it's not quite the right
codon going in there but it's close
enough and you get an amino acid put in
so that's one example
there's also suppression in the Alpha
viruses these viruses if you remember
have a plus strand RNA genome when they
are translated initially they make a
precursor or poly protein precursor
called P 1 2 3 it stops right here there
is a termination codon but what's beyond
it is an SP 4 which is the viral RNA
polymerase so it has to make this so
there is some suppression of this
termination codon now because both the
polymerase and this RNA polymerase are
enzymes you don't need to have a lot of
them because they're catalytic
so this suppression only happens about
five to ten percent of the time that the
ribosome comes down because you don't
need a hundred percent translation
because they're not structural protein
so this works gives you a little bit of
enzyme aid and that's how the virus
accesses this coding sequence so they're
cut to two kinds of suppressions
there are specific suppressor T RNAs
that recognize these three termination
codons and they put in a specific amino
acid so for example there is a
suppressor tRNA that will recognize the
Terminator UGA it puts Celino cysteine
in a rare amino acid and then there are
normal TR and
is that miss Reid termination codons
which is what I told you about then we
have ribosomal frame shifting so to get
back to your question when you have
overlapping reading frames than one
another retrovirus the mRNA again
encodes gag and Paul remember in the
retrovirus I just showed you the gag and
Paul were separated by a terminator here
the gag and Pol are in two different
reading frames which overlap so how do
you get both proteins made well you have
in fact in infected cells you get gag
made and you get a gag Paul fusion and
the back gag Paul fusion can be cleaved
by a protease to release the polymerase
this is made by ribosomal frame shifting
basically the ribosomes 5 to 10% of the
time they reach the end of gag they back
up a base and shift to another reading
frame so they glue they shift in this
case to the minus 1 reading frame and
now they can translate the Paul gene
which is in the minus 1 frame with
respect to the gag that's why it's
called the ribosomal frame shifting ok
that's another way to make a protein
that you normally can't access and
here's here's how this happens here
these frame shiftings usually happen at
a what's called a slippery sequence it
has a lot of ease and use so the
ribosome gets somewhat confused so here
you have our normal reading of of this
triplet this uua but now the trna slips
back one so we've gone here to minus 1
we're back 1 so now you see this a is
basically this u is base paired with
this a here and then then the next
triplet to be recognized is going to be
a UA instead of you a G which in this
case would be a terminator so now you
start and you continue the protein so
the next codon that will be read is not
a terminator it's it's an insertion of
an amino acid so you've slipped back to
the minus 1 frame and now you can access
the rest of that open reading frame so
it's a very simple minus 1 slippage
right here ribosomal frame shifting ok
so those are a couple of ways that
viruses can make many proteins from one
messenger RNA now the other issue I want
to talk about is the regulation of
translation in virus infected cells and
as I said viruses want the entire
machinery dedicated to them they don't
want any cell proteins main and here's
one example of how viruses achieve that
so this is the initiation step which we
talked about here is the 40s subunit
attached to the RNA and here's the
ternary complex the Met tRNA if to gtp
and now that met tRNA is sitting down on
the Aug codon so remember I told you at
that step gtp is hydrolyzed to GDP a TI
f2 is released all right this is a very
important factor this if too because
what it has to do eventually is pick up
more met tRNA and do another round of
initiation but in order to do this to
pick up another tRNA and make a ternary
complex the GDP has to be exchanged for
gtp because GDP won't work can't be
hydrolyzed to release the energy that's
needed so there's a second protein
called if 2b which binds this if to
gdp and exchanges the gdp for GTP
so it's basically a guanine exchange
factor now we have GIF to with GTP and
it can go through this whole sequence
again ok now in cells there is a
mechanism to regulate this in this
pathway and it involves phosphorylation
of if 2 we'll talk about how that
happens in a moment basically if 2 is
phosphorylated you can see right here
under certain conditions when that
happens it binds very tightly to if to
B and it doesn't get released at this
step so you eventually soak up all the
if to be in the cell which happens to
be limiting and you can't get anymore
recycling of this e is 2 and translation
stops alright so in fact this is a
response of many cells to virus
infection they phosphorylate iif 2 with
the idea of halting virus infection and
maybe
preventing spread of the virus to other
cells and that phosphorylation of VI f2
is carried out by a number of different
protein kinases in cells they're called
if to alpha kinases one of them is
called p KR and others called perc and
another is called GC n - and they're all
they all have this kinase domain which
is involved in phosphorylating iif - and
we're going to talk about p KR and perc
today
now the p KR response is an antiviral
response of the cell so on the left here
we have a cell being infected by a virus
the cell senses that it's been infected
how it does so we'll talk about later on
and one of the responses to the presence
of virus in the cell is that the cell
makes interferon interferon is a protein
a series of proteins that are involved
in establishing an antiviral state in
cells these interferon molecules that
are made come out of the cell and they
bind to interferon receptors on the cell
surface and they then induced the
synthesis of a number of proteins that
have antiviral properties and one of
those proteins is PK r which is the
kinase that phosphorylates EEI f2 and so
when cells are infected the cells
respond by producing this protein which
is engineered to stop translation and
stop the infection now the way that this
works is that PKA Aras is normally
present at a very low level when it is
produced it needs to be activated so the
mRNA is induced by interferon it has to
be activated before it can phosphorylate
if 2 and what we think happens is when
viruses infect cells most of them
produce double-stranded RNA the
double-stranded RNA will will bind to PK
R which is shown here this this purple
orange brown molecule this is PK are
multiple molecules of PK are bind the
RNA and they phosphorylate each other
and that activates the kinase so PK R is
not active as it's produced it has to
bind double stranded RNA
in order to be activated so that it can
then go on to phosphorylate gif too so
PKR is induced and activated by virus
infected it is induced by interferon and
it is in a it is activated by the
presence of double-stranded RNA and its
activation leads to the inhibition of
host translation it is also a activator
of apoptosis
now viruses don't like this right they
don't want translation to be shut down
because they cannot make their viral
proteins so they have evolved almost
every virus has involved some mechanism
to evade this PKR pathway so that tells
you right away how important this is I'm
going to show you one of them and that's
a small RNA made by adenovirus this is a
big double-stranded DNA virus this RNA
is called va1 RNA it's rather short and
its function is to prevent activation of
PKR
so what happens is again remember PKR is
induced by virus infection it binds
double-stranded RNA which is produced in
virus infected cells and an adenovirus
infected cell it would be produced when
you get transcription of both strands of
DNA and the transcripts would be
complementary they would hybridize and
make double-stranded RNA this binds the
kinase and activates that you inhibit
protein synthesis what aDNA virus does
it makes this small RNA called varn a1
which binds one molecule of PK are not
more than 1 so PK r cannot activate
itself it cannot force phosphorylate
itself it cannot force forelady i f2 so
you don't get inhibition of protein
synthesis so that is a function of this
antagonist to prevent the PK or
inhibition of protein synthesis other
viruses take different approaches to
this here is an example of vaccinia
virus it makes a pseudo substrate that
mimics CIF 2 alpha so here's the
structure of GIF to alpha remember this
is the substrate for p KR this is the
protein that p KR phosphorylates then
that results in translation inhibition
it's normally phosphorylated here on
serine 51 vaccinia virus makes two
proteins in very large quantities which
are mimics of gif to alpha and these
basically take up all the PKR that is
produced so the PK are never gets to
phosphorylate if to alpha rather the PK
are works on these k3l and m156 are
proteins and never gets the
phosphorylate he if' to alpha so those
are just two examples and these are
examples of different how different
viruses antagonize this pathway the CIF
2 alpha a phosphorylation pathway may
have herpes influenza adenovirus back
yellows Hep C amazing and they're all
different mechanisms they have different
targets but they all the end result is
that they don't want gif to alpha
phosphorylated so obviously this is a
very important antiviral effect and
viruses have evolved a number of ways to
get around it now there's another gif 2
kinase in cells called perc that stands
for PK are like ER transmembrane kinase
ER is endoplasmic reticulum is p KR was
the first gif to alpha kinase discovered
this was subsequently found and it has
homology to p KR hence the name so what
happens here is that this kinase
responds to miss folded proteins in the
endoplasmic reticulum now p KR remember
response to double-stranded RNA perc
responds to miss folded proteins which
often happens in virus infected cells it
happens at other times as well if you
take away oxygen from cells or glucose
mutations toxins virus infected these
all cause miss folding of proteins in
the ER this triggers what's called the
unfolded protein response now the
unfolded protein response is a series of
proteins and signal transduction
pathways which says there are miss
folded proteins here we have to stop
making proteins until we can sort out
is going on all right we don't want to
make more proteins until we can stop
them as folding so that the UPR shuts
down translation how does it do it by
phosphorylation of if to alpha via this
kinase perc and so in many
virus-infected cells this happens as
well so here's the pathway you have our
ER normally you're making nicely folded
proteins in the ER you have some kind of
stress a toxin a virus infection the the
proteins become misfolded they're not in
their proper structure there is a
protein in the lumen of the ER club it
stands for binding protein it will bind
to miss folded proteins and as bit bolts
binds to more and more miss folded
proteins it's taken away from perk perk
is a transmembrane protein in the ER
it's normally inactive when bound to bip
when bip is titrated away because BIP is
binding the MS folded proteins perk
becomes active it dimerizes it
phosphorylates itself and then it can be
active and go on to phosphorylate iif to
alpha and this is another way that
viruses are responding to
sorry cells are responding to virus
infection to shut down translation and
again viruses have evolved ways to get
around this as well what cells do other
things as well we're just beginning to
learn these when they are stressed not
only do they activate this unfolded
protein response but they shut off
translation by putting mRNAs into what
are called stress granules so here's a
nicely translating mRNA you see that the
flying turkeys
these are ribosomes are coming around
the mo don't these look like turkeys
right they're flying turkeys they're
coming around translating it's a
circularized mrna you put some stress on
the cell you in fact that you put a
toxin on the cell has a mechanism to
shunt these into these stress granules
which are very specific collections in
the cytoplasm they have these mRNAs and
they have a variety of proteins that
make up the granule so you can actually
see these stress granules in the
cytoplasm by staining for these proteins
with antibodies and these are stalled
mRNAs the
ribosomes are frozen on the mRNA they're
not making protein so the cell is saying
again we're stressed we don't want to
make proteins it's a waste of energy so
let's stop translation until we can sort
this out and they put them in stress
granules so a virus infects a cell its
mRNAs get shunted into stress granules
this is not a good thing right it's not
good for the mRNA to be shunted in there
so what do viruses do they antagonize
the formation of stress granules here
West Nile virus and dengue virus
antagonize the incorporation of two
structural proteins into the stress
granule thereby blocking their
production and poliovirus
one of its proteinases 3c cleaves one of
these components g3 BP of the stress
granule so it prevents the formation of
these granules so that it's mRNAs are
not incorporated into them and it can
continue to be translated another level
of regulation of translation is a TI F 4
F and now we get to talk about why the
the red part at the end of VI f/4g is
broken so remember the ribosome is
brought to the mRNA by this complex
which is called AI F 4 F this protein
if 4g is cleaved in cells infected with
a variety of Pokorny viruses is cleaved
by viral protein aces right here and
that prevents this from translating a
capped mRNA but because these viruses
have an iris they don't need a cap so
they don't care and in fact 4G still can
bind the iris but it just doesn't bind
if 4e and if the RNA doesn't have a cap
that doesn't matter
so in polio virus infected cells at
different times after infection if we
look at the rate of protein synthesis
you see it declines initially very
rapidly so this is inhibition of cell
translation and then it is replaced with
viral protein synthesis and then the
cells died the shadow off is also shown
here this is a poly acrylamide gel where
the proteins are labeled with s 35
methionine you can see at time zero
after infection there are a lot of cell
proteins being made also at time one but
look at how an our three
you start to see an inhibition of
translation now at our five most of the
cell proteins are long no longer made
they are replaced by viral proteins
shown here so that is what is happening
in virus infected cells the cell
translation is shut down so that all of
the machinery can be devoted to
translating viral mRNAs and this is an
experiment that shows you the basis for
that inhibition so on the left is the
same experiment I just showed you it's a
time course of polio infection and we're
labeling proteins with s 35:19 so you
can see in this experiment shut off
starts to occur around 2 hours and 15
minutes post infection it's all shut
post is all shut off pretty much by 2 or
3/4 hours okay and these two are Western
blots using an antibody against the if4
gene
remember VI f/4g is that linker protein
that is cleaved in pakora infected cells
there are two kinds of if 4g in cells
the if4 g1 and - and you can see they
are both cleaved during infection
this one is cleaved starting at about an
hour in 15 minutes this one is cleaved
around 2 hours and 15 minutes so
actually the cleavage of 4 g2 really
correlates very nicely with the shut off
so again that's the protein that it is
cleaved right here near the N terminus
so cell messages can't be translated
because the ribosome can't be recruited
to the captain RNAs so that's the basis
for that so again it's shown
diagrammatically here
gif 4g is cleaved right here by a viral
protease that separates the if' 4G from
the rest of the molecule so it can't
support 5 prime end dependent
translation but this fragment here the C
terminal fragment of 4G is perfectly
good to bind irises so that's why the
virus translation continues to work even
when this 4G is cleaved and the last
thing I want to tell you about is
something relatively new for viruses and
it's a very exciting area of biology in
general micro rna's
which is part of this whole RNA
interference pathway in the cells there
are many different kinds of small RNAs
which we now know are not only important
for antiviral responses but for
regulating gene expression so micro RNAs
are a subset of that whole RNA
interference pathway these are very
small RNAs they're typically non-coding
they can be encoded by viruses or by the
cell and they're transcribed by pol two
or three and two sixty to seventy
nucleotide transcripts that are then
processed by enzymes to twenty one
nucleotide structures which then have
activity all right now in the cell these
are incredibly important for regulating
cell to cell genes they control gene
expression post transcriptionally by
either repressing translation or
degrading the mRNA and whether these
microRNAs do one or the other depends on
the complementarity of sequences within
the 3-prime non-coding region of the
messenger RNA I'll show you that in a
moment
so these microRNAs function to inhibit
our mRNA s in a protein complex they're
called micro rnps they have a couple of
cellular proteins here as you can see
and again the complementarity to the
three prime UTR of the message depends
whether the message is degraded where
translation is repressed and here's a
schematic of an interaction of a typical
micro RNA with the three prime UTR so
here's the end of the open reading frame
or termination codon would be here
usually they're binding about 15 more
than 15 nucleotides from the end of the
coding region there is typically
homology on either side of a bulge this
is how the micro rnas work and then the
extent of complementarity here depends
controls whether this interaction leads
to degradation of the mRNA or inhibition
of translation this is actually a very
active area of work right now to sort
out how this works
so these are the two ways that micro
rnas can
regulate translation which is what we've
been talking about today remember five
prime end dependent translation depends
on a ribosome being brought to the mRNA
via this kap-40
interaction so there there are some data
which suggest that the formation of a
micro RNP at the three prime non-coding
and inhibits this joining of the at the
five prime end either at the cap binding
step or the 60s joining stage now you
can see that this is possible because if
in fact the RNAs are circularized as we
suggested that would bring the micro
RNAs down to the three prime and to the
five prime end so that would repress
initiation here there's also some idea
that the micro arm piece can actually
affect elongation we haven't talked
about the regulation of the elongation
step at all just the initiation step but
there is regulation at that step and
perhaps micro rna's caused the ribosomes
to drop off at a higher rate so that's
how they might impact translation and of
course the other part which we're not
talking about is that they would degrade
the mRNAs directly so I just want to
leave you with a couple of examples of
how micro rnas play into virus
infections and again remember there are
both viral mRNAs and there are cellular
cellular micro RNAs which have different
roles so here's an example of a cellular
micro RNA is called Mir 122 it's made
only in the liver in US and it's
required for hepatitis C virus
replication so Hep C is hepatic tropic
it doesn't replicate anywhere else as
far as we know and this is probably
because mirror is a liver specific micro
RNA and this mere bind is the 5-prime
non-coding region of Hep C very close to
the iris and somehow allows the virus to
replicate people are just trying to sort
out how that works so no mirror no Hep C
replication so guess what companies are
trying to design ways to target Mir 122
as an anti Hep C therapy you can do that
you can design complementary RNAs that
will
buying the mirror and take it out of
circulation there are also micro rna's
in the cell that are anti viral and they
can either target viral genes so they
can you can have a cellular Mir that
would inhibit the production of a viral
protein and inhibit viral replication or
in some in many cases there are specific
cellular genes that are needed for virus
replication so the mirrors which are
cellular mirrors are actually reducing
the expression of those cellular genes
that are needed for the virus and that
reduces virus replication so those are
cellular mirrors that have some role we
have a positive effect on virus
replication than some mirrors inhibit
virus replication and then we have virus
encoded micro RNAs and so far we have
slightly more than 200 that have been
identified in these six different virus
families a lot of them in the herpes
viruses as you can see some controversy
about whether there they really exist in
retroviruses or not but these appear to
have a variety of effects during
infection many of them block apoptosis
so programmed cell death is a response
of cells to virus infection the cell
wants to die so that viruses cannot be
produced so there are many in a virus of
course doesn't like that especially
viruses with long replication cycles the
virus does not want apoptosis to occur
so these mirrors block apoptosis that is
their function that produced from the
virus genome and they block apoptosis
there are also examples of mirrors that
block immune responses which we may hear
about from dr. Silverstein many cells go
into cell cycle arrest when they are
infected and remember DNA viruses need
that DNA replication machinery to be
active so the mirrors prevent the cell
cycle arrest and many others promote
latency of viruses the ability to remain
with the cell for long periods so these
are pretty new areas of research and
this is
going to be explored really in an
interesting way in coming years how
these viral and cellular mirrors have an
interplay and how they result in either
an infection or not this is something we
didn't even know about five years ago
you